[Música]
y
las autoridades ucranianas surgen a los
ciudadanos agua en la región del donbass
a medida que las fuerzas rusas
concentran sus esfuerzos en esa zona el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
advirtió que en la ciudad de boro dianca
la situación es más horrorosa que una
cercana lucha
en el estado mexicano de baja california
también se sienten las consecuencias de
la guerra en ucrania hasta allí llegan
ucranianos huyendo de su país para
intentar cruzar hasta eeuu en donde
esperan recibir asilo político tenemos
reporte desde tijuana
y la jueza que está brawn jackson hace
historia y se convertirá en la primera
afroamericana en la corte suprema de
justicia de eeuu tras ser confirmada por
el senado con el voto de tres
republicanos
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 si rodrigo se dan hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos en el día 43 de la
invasión rusa ucrania las autoridades
ucranianas avisaron a los habitantes del
donbass que se encuentran ante la última
oportunidad de salir de la zona los
ataques rusos se concentran ahora en el
este del país en donde rusia anunció que
destruyó cuatro depósitos de
almacenamiento de combustible pero él
cree en lima admitió pérdidas
significativas aunque si dar cifras de
soldados fallecidos entretanto el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr zelinski
aseguró que en la ciudad de boro dianca
la situación es significativamente más
terrible que en la cercana ducha
a vos audis robot sipo ros empezó el
trabajo de análisis del cierre abro
bianca es significativamente mucho más
espantoso allí aún más víctimas de los
ocupantes sean rusos qué pasará cuando
el mundo conozca toda la verdad sobre lo
que hicieron los militares jan rusos en
mariupol allí en casi todas las calles
está lo que se vio en muchas otras
ciudades de la región de kiev tras la
retirada de las tropas rusas la misma
crueldad y los mismos crímenes terribles
casos tukis aquí estos estuches la
comunidad internacional sigue
presionando a través de sanciones para
lograr una desescalada del conflicto
rusia fue suspendida del consejo de
derechos humanos de la onu una medida
que moscú critica por ilegal al tiempo
que fue bienvenida por ucrania mientras
que la unión europea impuso un embargo
al carbón ruso
una decisión trascendental el 7 de abril
rusia fue suspendida del consejo de
derechos humanos de la onu bajo el
argumento de violaciones y abusos
sistemáticos cometidos durante su
invasión a ucrania en feb a nine
destruir el resultado es el siguiente a
favor 93 en contra 24 abstenciones 58 el
proyecto de resolución se adopta y
previo a la votación los representantes
de ucrania y rusia se pronunciaron
todo lo que necesita hacer es presionar
el botón sirve para el consejo de
derechos humanos y muchas vidas en
el rating presionar no significa apretar
un gatillo
hoy no es el momento ni el lugar para el
teatro o este tipo de actuaciones como
la presentada por un cronista estilo
presstv club crime a través de un
comunicado el gobierno ruso rechazó su
suspensión
la parte rusa considera que la
resolución adoptada por la asamblea
general de la onu el 7 de abril en nueva
york para suspender la membresía de la
fe rusa en el consejo de derechos
humanos de la onu es un paso ilegal y
políticamente motivado para castigar
desafiantemente a un estado miembro
soberano de la onu a más de 5.800
kilómetros de nueva york en bruselas los
ministros de relaciones exteriores de
los países miembros de la otan debatían
sobre más ayudas para ucrania y
condenaron lo ocurrido en la ciudad
ucraniana de bushehr
d'atri nos hemos acordado que debemos
fortalecer y mantener aún más nuestro
apoyo a ucrania para que el país
prevalezca frente a la invasión rusa
horrores en rage pese a que las
esperanzas están puestas en encontrar
una solución a través del diálogo los
integrantes del g7 anuncian nuevas
sanciones económicas y financieras en
contra de rusia al tiempo que el
parlamento europeo votó en favor de una
resolución para pedir sanciones
adicionales entre ellas un embargo total
a las importaciones de petróleo gas y
carbón procedente de rusia
consecuencia de la guerra es también el
éxodo de millones de personas algunos
han llegado hasta el estado mexicano de
baja california para intentar cruzar
hasta eeuu en donde esperan recibir
asilo político nuestra corresponsal en
tijuana anabel ya goodman tiene más
detalles
desde finales de febrero en que comenzó
este conflicto bélico entre rusia y
ucrania miles de ellos o millones han
tenido que dejar sus hogares en promedio
y según estima la onu cerca de 3
millones de ucranianos que han tenido
que buscar mejores oportunidades de vida
en nuestro país y según las autoridades
del instituto de inmigración bueno son
cerca de 9000 los ucranianos que han
llegado en las últimas fechas en este
par de meses y baja california es uno de
los estados fronterizos que colinda
justamente con eeuu pues está recibiendo
la presencia de estos grupos estamos en
un albergue aquí en la zona centro de la
ciudad donde se les está proveyendo de
alimento de un lugar donde dormir en las
literas se les da ropa se les da también
atención médica algunos consultorios y
parte vital de ello ha sido justamente
los voluntarios los connacionales de
ellos personas ucranianas que ya son
ciudadanos norteamericanos y que han
venido incluso de distintos estados de
la unión americana para proporcionar
ayuda a sus connacionales se cree que
por día están saliendo cerca de 500 de
ellos en camiones aquí en las
inmediaciones de la garita de san ysidro
que está a unos 510 minutos de este
lugar ubicado en la zona centro de
tijuana para poder ser entrevistados por
las autoridades y buscar el tan anhelado
pues asilo político y este apoyo por
parte de las autoridades y bueno además
de los voluntarios hay muchos familiares
de ellos que también se han dado cita
que están viniendo a apoyar y a dar pues
esas palabras de aliento y esa ayuda a
las personas que continúan en este
albergue y que están también ubicados en
otros hoteles de la ciudad mientras se
resuelve su situación migratoria en la
información desde tijuana baja
california méxico
cambiamos de tema porque el senado de
eeuu confirmó a qué tangi brawn jackson
como jueza de la corte suprema- marcando
un hito en la historia al ser la primera
afroestadounidense en la máxima
autoridad judicial de la nación 50
congresistas y tres republicanos votaron
a su favor frente a los 47 votos en
contra aún está pendiente la
ratificación en la cámara de
representantes donde los demócratas
tienen la mayoría
de tangi brawn jackson de 51 años fue
nominada por el presidente
estadounidense joe biden para el cargo
el pasado 25 de febrero el mandatario
demócrata elogió la dedicación
inquebrantable al estado de derecho de
la jueza busque una candidata para la
corte suprema con credenciales
excepcionales característas hable y una
dedicación inquebrantable al estado de
derecho conozca a mi candidata la jueza
que tania brawn jackson hija de un
abogado y una maestra de escuela pública
cursó sus estudios de abogacía en la
universidad de harvard su carrera inició
siendo secretaria del juez liberal
stephen breyer y es a su mentor a quien
ahora podría sustituir en el alto
tribunal durante años trabajó como
abogada de oficio para acusados de
delitos que no podían permitirse una
defensa en 2012 el ex presidente
demócrata barack obama la nominó para el
puesto de jueza federal del distrito de
washington y fue confirmada un año
después en los cuatro días de audiencias
de confirmación en el senado
varios republicanos la acusaron de ser
indulgente en la condena de delincuentes
de pornografía infantil y se defendió a
sí
knightley response deudor y he sido
jueza durante casi una década y me tomo
muy en serio esa responsabilidad y mi
deber de ser independiente decido los
casos desde una postura neutral evalúo
los hechos e interpretó y aplicó la ley
a los hechos del caso que tengo ante mí
sin miedo ni favoritismos en consonancia
con mi juramento judicial
el ex de los 115 jueces nombrados en los
233 años de historia del tribunal
supremo 108 han sido hombres blancos
nos vamos ahora hasta perú porque allí
se vivió una nueva jornada de protestas
en contra de la gestión del gobierno de
pedro castillo estas movilizaciones
nacieron por el alza en los precios de
los combustibles y derivaron en un
reclamo general al presidente nuestro
corresponsal francisco zacarías nos
resumía previamente la jornada
las confederaciones sindicales obreros y
la educación realizaron una jornada
nacional de lucha para exigir al
presidente pedro castillo adoptar
acciones más adecuadas para enfrentar
a la vida de millones de peruanos debido
al incremento de los combustibles y de
los productos de la canasta básica
familiar los manifestantes se
movilizaron por las principales calles
de lima se siente desilusionados con
castillos que exigen al mandatario
frenar la inflación acabar con la
imposición de medidas improvisadas como
el inconstitucional 'toque de queda' del
martes 5 de abril luchar contra la
corrupción defender la economía popular
y cubiertos de promesas electorales
un fuerte contingente policial en riesgo
del palacio del gobierno y el entorno
del parlamento para evitar los males que
la marcha como premios emmy rechazar al
mandatario izquierdista por no haber
ejecutado acciones para enfrentar al
neoliberalismo lo acusan de
supuestamente haber negociado con
sectores de derecha para mantenerse en
el carbono durante el cubrimiento de
esta jornada algunos ciudadanos me
dijeron que las protestas continuarán
mientras pedro castillo no realice
mejoras que les permita salir del
estancamiento social y económico en el
que perú se encuentra actualmente
francia elige este domingo a su próximo
presidente para un mandato de 5 años 12
candidatos aspiran a llegar al palacio
del elíseo los invitamos este 10 de
abril a conectarse con nuestro especial
a partir del mediodía hora de bogotá
quito y lima hasta aquí este informativo
sigan conectados
[Música]